I was younger I was always obsessed with
the idea of how TV worked I think from
the age of four I couldn't even work out
how people inspired the TV and I always
just used to speak to my parents I was
like how can I get a job in
entertainment how can I do something
that I enjoy and get paid for at the
same time and I came from a really tiny
little village in Norfolk so we had no
kind of connections it wasn't much I
could really doing the idea of
entertainment supposed to write my own
or radio shows and record them on
cassette and then play them to everyone
at school and that led to me going into
stage school led me into becoming a
dancer and then I moved to London when I
was 19 and decided that I wanted to
learn how to be worked and start to go
for auditions I think being a TV host
depends on the kind of show you present
I think for me it's definitely learning
to be a good listener because an
interview isn't so much just question
and answer it's conversation so instead
of writing out a list of questions that
you want to ask it's more about listen
to what someone's saying and then ask
them about what they've just said and
I've learned that throughout actually
becoming a presenter and with each job
I've done but the kind of shows I do
it's about me and upbeat it's about
letting the person who you're
interviewing being able to trust you I
suppose of the job I do it's about being
as reactive as possible
I think I've done a variety of shows and
each one's been really special in its
own way but I've always been attracted
to entertainment shows family
entertainment shows live TV shows I
think the reason I work in TV is because
I get a creative buzz of everything I do
every day is different every show is
different and I think I'm drawn to also
working as a team I think when I first
got into presenting I think I thought
that being the presenter you have
separate to everyone else but it's so
important that you work as a team not
just on your own and learn how the
production works because that's really
important more than just standing there
and reading a script and it's also I
find it really important like write your
own script put it into your own words
and more importantly write your own
questions I always think it's important
to have a good night out with your whole
team before you start on a show because
if you go into a roomful of strangers
it's always gonna be a little bit static
because you got to get to know each
other it's sort of like becoming a
family it's like becoming a big group of
friends it's working away when you work
abroad almost is a lot easier to make a
TV show because you have to get to know
each other so well and you do become
like this little team that makes
something the project is all of yours
so friendship is really important when
making TV I think probably the most
challenging moment for me working on
live TV was probably working on The X
Factor when I hosted the main share with
Olly and that purely came with the
pressure and there were moments that
sometimes went a little bit wrong and
you have to try and work your way around
it and at the time it felt like the
worst moment the worst thing that could
ever happen but looking back it's just a
learning curve because you know at the
end of the day you're making
entertainment shows you're not saving
lives but it is your job and you're
trying to do it the best you can and
things go wrong you learn from them and
you move on it's sometimes in life to me
when things go wrong it it it can be fun
there was a moment when I used to host
the jungle and we'd written the whole
script and I was reading it all on
AutoKey and we'd rehearse the show and
during the show Katie Price had walked
out so my producer said in my ear don't
want to alarm you Katie Price's just
walked out the jungle what you're about
to read on your author key will be
completely different to what you read in
rehearsal but just go with it so I
couldn't talk I couldn't say what about
to exercise on TV but I just did it
and it was it was that buzzy live
feeling that you get and by the end of
the show everyone was like yeah that was
great
but that's TV it's really enjoyable
advice to work in as a TV presenter is
get to know what every single person's
job is on TV in the production no one's
more important than anyone else
everyone is vital to that production and
once you know how everything works
around you it makes your job a lot
easier and I think everyone knows that
with each other yeah but that's the fun
part
Lona learn how the creative process
works on TV and it's such a fun job to
have
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]